Good morning church.
Uh, this is, uh, a great day that we get to celebrate
'cause we have Parker Robertson, who is a sixth grade boy,
uh, getting baptized this morning.
So praise God for that.
Um, yeah, Yeah.
Just to give you a little bit about Parker's story,
we were at kids camp together this past summer and
after the first nights we were walking out
and he shared with me that, uh,
he wasn't really sure if he had a relationship with Jesus
and he really wanted to.
And so through that week we talked through that.
And, uh, as the, uh, months have gone on, he has continued
to have these conversations with his parents.
And so now he is ready to step forward
and proclaim his faith to us.
And so, uh, Parker, based on your confession
of faith in Jesus Christ, I now get
to baptize you in the name of the Father Son
and the Holy Spirit.